let's break it down read the first three
verses let's break it down since you
mentioned that
Miracle nine
okay yep John 9 verses 18 that's the
miracle of the blind man but read the
first three verses let's unpack the meat
guys pray for us to be filled with the
spirit to do justice to these passages
this is really great man as he went
along he saw a a man blind from birth
now before you go on he was born blind
right because here a lot of people don't
read this attentively they gloss over it
he came out of his mother's womb
blind keep that in mind okay now keep
reading a rabbi who sinned this man or
his parents that he was born blind now
notice the irony of the question they're
assuming that the man had sinned which
is why he came out of his mother's womb
blind now if you're not paying attention
that means means they assume that
children could sin in their mother's
womb did you catch it yeah wow because
they're saying who sin did he sin or his
parents that he's born blind but hold on
if you're blaming his blindness on his
sin but you realize he came out blind
that means you're assuming he sinned in
the
womb because why would he come out blind
for any sin he committed without this
implying
that the Jews believe that unborn
children even in their mother's womb
could sin against God and bring upon
punishment you caught it yeah I wonder
if they would take that from like uh
where Jacob was holding exactly where
they took it from exactly Genesis 25:22
to 26 because it says that Jacob and his
twin brother Esau were wrestling with
each other in their mother's womb
causing their mother to panic because
she thought something wrong with the
children The Unborn children so they're
already fighting each other in their
mother's womb now notice Jesus doesn't
correct it in saying you guys don't know
what you're talking about he doesn't
deny that someone in the womb may do
something that's displeasing to the Lord
or that people can suffer the
consequences of the sins of their
parents he simply says in this case it's
neither him nor his parents that
resulted in him being born blind because
what is our Lord's response in verse
three neither this man nor his parents
sin said Jesus but this happened so that
the works of God might be displayed in
him and yet in John 5 verses 1- 14 you
don't need to turn there let me just
explain the man who had been paralyzed
whom Jesus healed on the Sabbath he
warned them see that you do not sin L
something worse happens to you John 5:14
real quickly go there and show them John
5:14 after healing the paralytic the man
who was paralyzed healing the paralyzed
man Jesus warns him don't sin L
something worse happens to you so Jesus
acknowledges that certain sins can bring
about physical ailments and diseases and
suffering okay it says later Jesus found
him at the temple and said to him see
you are made well again stop sinning or
something worse may happen to you you
see so Jesus acknowledges some physical
diseases ailments and suffering can be
the result of sin either your own sin or
the sin of your parents because God
allows that
even those who are under the
headship or who belong to a certain
family or a tribe to suffer the result
of the sins of let's say
let me give you an example so people can
see where I'm going with this imagine a
woman who's addicted to crack she gets
pregnant and she gives birth to a crack
baby which is something that happens
notice the child came out deformed as a
result of the crack addiction and sin of
the mother that doesn't mean God hates
the child or God will condemn and punish
the child in hell for the sin of the
parent but it means that God has created
Humanity in such a way whether we like
it or not our actions will affect those
who are connected to us either our
children our parents our siblings
because we're considered being part of
the same
body this is known as corporate
solidarity is everyone so everyone clear
on that and you're you're you get the
point too brother yes but in the case of
the blind man Jesus makes clear not
everyone who suffers a disease or an
ailment a physical
deformity suffers because of some sin
that he or she or his or her parents
committed sometimes this is just the
result of the fall when Adam and Eve sin
their sin brought about destruction and
Decay to all creation even to children
who can come out with a physical disease
or deformity not because of Any sin they
commit in the womb or the sin of their
parents but this is just the nature of
the Fallen World so we have to be
careful not
every person who comes out with a
deformity or an illness is suffering
because of some sin he or she committed
in the womb or as a consequence of the
sins of their parents it simply may be
the result that due to the Fallen
condition of the world due to our bodies
being broken and not functioning at
their optimal level
at times sometimes children will come
out suffering diseases or deformities
but that's not a punishment for the sins
of their parents or the sins they commit
in the womb so let's be clear but in
certain instances some people do come
out with diseases deformities
afflictions because of sin so I want to
be clear on that in the case of the
paralyzed man Jesus warns him see stop
sinning or something worse will happen
in other words your ailment is because
of your sin but in the of the blind man
he wasn't born blind because any of any
sin he committed or his parents
committed but God would use the
blindness to glorify himself is that
clear yeah thank you that's awesome now
read 4 to8 because now I'm going to show
you something amazing verses 48 uh this
is in uh John 8 John N John nine all
right as long as it is day we must do
the uh we must do the works of him who
sent to me night is coming when no man
can work while I am in the world I am
the light of the world Amen now notice
how he takes blindness physical
blindness as a metaphor of being
spiritually blind and needing the
spiritual light of the Gospel of Jesus
Christ to be able to spiritually
see make the connection yeah when you're
blind everything is dark it's
Darkness so Jesus takes physical
blindness as an example of spiritual
blindness and just like he has the power
to make people physically see he has the
power to make you spiritually see and so
you learn another important lesson every
physical Miracle is intended to point to
a greater spiritual reality lazarus's
physical Resurrection is meant to point
to Jesus's ability to raise you
spiritually so you can live forever in
his presence but now notice how he
physically heals
him uh after saying this he spit on the
ground and made some mud with a saliva
and he put it on the Man's eyes go he
told them watch wash in the pool of
silom this word means scent y so the man
went and washed and came home
seeing now watch before you finish watch
what our Lord did he spit on what the
ground and then from that spit and let's
say the dust of the ground he placed it
on the Man's eyes and then the man went
in the water and came out seeing right
yes okay so did you read all the way to
eth because I'm GNA show you something I
didn't read eight you want me to read
eight reading it okay his neighbors and
those who had formerly seen him begging
asked isn't this the same man who used
to sit and beg
and then then he answered in verse 9 I
am but now
notice Jesus spits on the ground spit on
the ground and from the ground he formed
eyeballs from the man because he
took the dust of the ground that he spit
on put it on the Man's eyes and then he
went into the water came out seeing now
let me explain to you why he did this go
to Genesis 2: 4 to7 let me make the
connection with the Genesis account of
creation
okay
Genesis 2: 4-7
okay I like what I am not Aisha said
glasses are made of sand
exactly
two4 okay
okay the this is the account of the
heavens and the earth when they were
created when the Lord God made the earth
and the
heavens now no shrub had yet appeared on
Earth
and no plant had yet sprung up for the
Lord God had not sent rain on the earth
and there was no one to work the ground
but streams came up from the earth and
watered the whole face of the ground
then the Lord God formed a man and from
the dust of the ground he breathed into
his nostrils the breath of life and the
Man became a living being I don't think
you caught the connection with Jesus as
Creator because notice in order for God
to create man from the dust the ground
had to be first moistened by a Mist it
had to be watered right okay oh yeah you
sure got yes he had not SED rain but but
streams came up I know that another
version says like a Mist comes up yeah a
Mist came that
moistened the dust watered the dust from
which man's eyeballs ears and body were
formed
okay so where did our eyeballs come from
Adam's eyeballs from the dust his eyes
his ears his mouth his teeth all his
organs were formed from that dust after
it had been moistened watered by a
Mist how did Jesus create this man's
Eyes by moistening the dust of the
ground with his spit showing that he is
the one who creates and gives life
Hallelujah okay now but he also went
into the the pool the water right salom
yes right yes why because now I want you
to go to Genesis 1: one or
two
okay okay all right in the beginning God
created the heavens and the earth now
the Earth was formless and empty
Darkness was over the surface of the
deep and the spirit of God hovering over
the waters did you catch the connection
the Earth in its Prebiotic State meaning
when it was
formless and uninhabitable it was in its
Prebiotic State meaning this is the
stage of the Earth where life was
uninhabitable who's now hovering over
the water of the deep the spirit so here
imagine the Earth has a gaseous Mass
it's a watery surface and the spirit is
hovering over that watery surface to now
make the Earth livable and habitable so
the spirit works with water to bring
life to make the earth a place that will
sustain life notice water and the spirit
Spirit working with water to bring about
life the man enters the water and comes
out
seeing Spirit hovering over the watery
deep in order to make earth habitable
and life permitting Spirit using water
to bring life john 35 you must be born
of water and Spirit in order to be born
a new born from above born again and
enter the Kingdom of
Heaven Hallelujah
wow you know one thing a theme that I'm
seeing in a lot of things that uh you're
saying tonight uh is that there's a
little thing that that people have to do
the you know the uh you know the the
disciples had to ask invite Jesus to
come to the house you know uh Jesus
knocks the door we have to open the door
you know and this blind man he had to go
wash off the Clay in the water there's a
little thing that's required there's
some kind of response that's required
from us but and if we don't do that
response we could miss the miracle you
know and yeah so you're seeing how in
John Jesus is recreating the creation
that he brought into being that had now
been fallen and tainted he's restoring
it in other words this is the word who
at the beginning created the heavens and
the Earth and gave life to all creation
he's now recreating this Fallen World
and restoring it this is what you're
supposed to see everyone are you getting
it in fact I'm going to give you further
proof that this is what you're supposed
to see just like Jesus created the first
man from dust that had been moistened by
water and from that dust produced his
eyeballs that same Jesus now restored
the man's sight by
recreating eyeballs for him from the
dust that had been moistened by his
spittle right right okay now what did
the god do to make Adam a living Soul it
says he breathed into his nostrils the
breath of life and Man became a living
Soul became fully animated
right is that what Genesis 2:7 said
right when you read it became a living
Soul yes yes right after when God
breathed into him his nostrils the
breath of life which is a metaphor for
the spirit being sent forth to give life
to Adam and animate him by producing a
soul within him right yes okay now
notice what Jesus did in John
2022 go to John
2022 peace be with you as the father
hath sent me even so I am sending you
and when he had said this he breathed on
them and said unto them receive the Holy
Spirit okay now even though I said read
22 you decided to read 21 I love how you
just ignore me because it's your world
buddy but 22 what did he do on them uh
he breathes on them yes no not only
breathe on them breathe what the holy
spirit said receive the Holy Spirit the
same god Jehovah God that breathed into
Adam's nostrils the Breath of Life to
make him alive is the same God who's now
breathing that Breath of Life the Holy
Spirit to make them spiritually alive
and to empower them to do the work of
God hallelujah amen are you catching how
John is portraying Jesus as the Jehovah
God of Genesis who created and gave life
yes
Hallelujah H I love John man I love that
I love that and ironically brother since
we're mentioning the Quran in chapter
3:49 and chapter 5: 110 how did Jesus
give life to the clay bird he created
from clay the shape of a bird breathed
blew into it and it came to life became
a living bird Allah permitted to do so
so even the Chron ackn knowledge is
Jesus
possesses the spirit of life and he can
blow out breathe out that spirit that
gives life even the Quran acknowledges
that